how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the mcu and
yesterday the new
mutants came out in theaters that's
right after
years of delays new mutants is finally
out i saw it yesterday it was an okay
movie i'll do a review on it later but
the big thing that everybody is talking
about
is that they actually showed a black
widow trailer before the premiere of new
mutants
and a lot of people have been asking me
about it but it is just
the final trailer that they already
showed several months ago
so it's not a new trailer however at the
end they did mention
the date that black widow was coming out
and where you can expect to see it and
there is a rumor right now that marvel
studios could be releasing a new black
widow trailer pretty soon and i'll talk
about everything that you need to know
in this video but first if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you stay up to date
on all the latest mcu news and so you
can enter this week's giveaway for a
chance to win a deadpool versus cable
funko pop
all you have to do to enter is subscribe
to my channel like this video and leave
a comment down below
so right now what everybody is wondering
is that since mulan is going to video on
demand on what disney calls
premiere access is black widow going to
go on premiere access as well and skip a
theatrical release
and it's kind of a big deal right now
because a lot of people think that she
deserves to have a theatrical release
while on the other hand some people
don't want to go to the movie theaters
because of the risk of getting sick
which is perfectly understandable
however now most of the major theater
chains have
opened and as of right now it looks like
they're going to remain
open meaning that black widow is still
on schedule for its november release
and at the end of this black widow
trailer that of course
marvel strategically placed before the
new mutants
it says that black widow will be
released on november 6th
2020 and it says that it's still coming
to dolby cinema
reald 3d and imax so as of right now
black widow is still set for a
theatrical release despite disney
announcing their disney plus premiere
access video on demand program now of
course there is the possibility that
they could be releasing it in theaters
and on premiere access for disney plus
this would make the most sense seen as
how the people who want to go see it in
the theaters could go
and the people who don't want to risk
getting sick could watch it at home
and that would ultimately be a win-win
for everybody
everybody would pretty much get what
they want and there could be an
announcement for it soon where basically
two months away from black widow we're
almost in september and according to a
report not too long ago marvel seemingly
has made two new black widow trailers
and there's no doubt that they're saving
these trailers for when we get closer to
black widow and they'll most likely
announce if they're still going to be in
theaters or if they're going to video on
demand but again right now everything
still points to natasha getting a
theatrical release
so since movie theaters are open until
disney says otherwise black widow is
going to be headed to theaters on
november 6th
so let me know what you think about this
would you like to see her in theaters or
will you be watching her
at home even if she does get a
theatrical release let me know what you
think in the comments down below
and don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest
mcu news for live updates you can follow
me on twitter and instagram
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you